have you been watching his stuff
recently no he's getting a little bit
more comfortable in front of the camera
he's kind of like [__] he's doing more
of these faces
oh he's doing a lot more of these I want
to see this jaw hinge you're talking
about it's oh man there's one do you
want to watch one of them yeah jockle
jaw hands yeah they're Jackal jaw hinge
it's a it's his signature move so
tonight's dish is gonna be fettuccine
Bolognese also I'm gonna start heating
up the water for my pasta
okay
[__] hits he knew what he did right
there
that's a little o face yeah I like that
weird jaw thing you do yeah
yeah you treat me around I might do it
more that's what I'm saying you might
maybe make me do it all night carbon
damn revising so doing the best I can
right now oh
it's that [__] serving man I love it